okay let's go to our next caller from
the 508 area code a surefire way to get
on the show is called from a
massachusetts area code caller from 508
go ahead yeah I got the final right area
code I'm actually calling from one - oh
I mean messing up on you but I'll still
take a question hey I appreciate your
show me Lebanon pay attention to
everything that you're doing and I like
you come with a mostly neutral you the
biggest question I had is you've been
kind of the critic of both the less than
the right the more so they're all great
in there
why did entity politics it deeply and we
wanted to know what your personal
opinion was about identity politics
overall because it now seems that both
sides are playing it pretty heavy yeah
do you think that it's good do you think
that it's bad what do you see happening
in the future with it because it does
seem to be relatively new concept I
guess is at least in popularity
okay so cut let's go a lot of good stuff
in there first of all I don't think
identity politics is necessarily new
it's really been around since been
around for decades builder hunting used
a version of identity politics I do
think that the way in which it's being a
right now or used has shifted a little
bit here's my thought about identity
politics and this goes back to my story
the other day where I said most things
are kind of a gray area you've got your
critics of identity politics and then
you've got your sort of perpetuators of
identity politics I think that identity
politics where I come down is as follows
and then you tell me whether this makes
any sense to you it's important to
recognize and listen to the experiences
that people bring to discussions of
political nature socio-cultural issues
etc based on their experiences as
members of a an identity group whether
it's a religious identity group a racial
identity group gender whatever we should
listen to their voices we should
understand how it is that their
membership in that identity group
relates to the political issues that
we're discussing what I disagree with is
the identity becoming a sort of trump
card and it's almost like a pun to say
trump card at this point because the
but it doesn't become a trump card and
it doesn't it can't be a silencer of
other ideas from people who maybe are
not part of that same identity group so
that that's where I come down and I know
people hear me say that and they'll just
repeat so are you for identity politics
or are you against it and it's like I
all I can do is repeat the same answer
which is we should be conscious and
appreciative of those elements of
identity but they don't supersede all
debate on any particular issue now
that's that's about what I would expect
and I you know what I actually I'm
completely agree with you I'm hoping
that a lot of I'm hoping that the mass
majority of people come to that
conclusion as well because it does seem
like is that a lot of lines drawn in the
sand as you're saying and a lot of
silencing voices and other opinions
rather than listening and you know I
went on a I was so I've been a leftist
for the majority of my adulthood and I
kind of recently started to listen to
other ideas and as a white male wow
they're speaking to me and then
obviously I go dig a little bit deeper
and I realize it okay none of this is
really based in fact but it did bring
the awareness to what you just said and
hopefully well come across that I think
what you're doing will maybe open up
some eyes and ears to that I hope so
alright really appreciate the call
it's sort of starting to get a
connection issue so I'm gonna let you go
but really do appreciate hearing from
you and hope to hear from you again